that's me bub
160 years old and having my heart broken
for the millionth time
how did it all go so wrong
well if you ask me it all started back
when i met a man named xavier
no not that one the other one
in today's modern world where
conversations of acceptance tolerance
community and laser eyes are so
prominent you'd think x-men would be a
bigger hit for touching on all of that
but as it is
x-men is in that nebulous ralph boner
void between projects after disney
purchased 20th century fox and were left
with a dearth of x-men content
will they be brought back with the same
cast via the multiverse and doctor
strange 2 will they be recast with a hot
young new group of photogenic
20-somethings that have a lot of
followers on the gram
who knows i can't keep track of what's
happening anymore so my prediction is
that all the x-men will be former
employees of tony stark that want
revenge because he called them freaks
and weirdos at a party once in 2004.
seeing as how it's going to be a while
before we get more x-men on the big or
possibly small screen it might be fun to
take a look back at their first
successful outing as a cross-media
adaptation you'd think that it wasn't
until the grounded and serious
live-action take that x-men adaptations
would touch on the more grounded and
serious themes but i think that the
x-men of the 90s accomplished that just
as much as the movies did and maybe a
bit more while also being full of depth
and love for the source material you
know instead of unbridled shame but
before we get too much further into all
that 90s saturday morning cartoon
goodness i got a secret to tell you it's
really important so hear me out lean in
because i want you to focus on this one
there's just been something really
bothering me lately and i feel like not
enough people are talking about it
there's this thing going around that
maybe you've heard of it has global pvp
massive pve boss battles 600 plus
champions and it seems like no one on
youtube is talking about this video is
sponsored by rain shadows
if you've heard of raid shadow legends
you know it's got more champions than
you can shake a magic staff at over 600
now but it's also got an insane level of
variety for bosses too let's put one of
those guys in the spotlight today the
guardian of the void keep malik kavar
this guy was the priest of light at one
point but he had an epiphany while
stargazing one night whether he was
right or not his fellow priests didn't
care much for it and they kicked him to
the curb for speaking such philosophical
gobbledygook lucky for us he went off to
master the magic art of the void so we
have a nice supply of void potions to
ascend our champions with not so lucky
for us he has a nasty attitude about the
whole being exiled thing so he's not
giving up his potions without a fight
the main trick to fighting malik is
dealing with all the poison he puts out
it's a lot and he has an ability that
deals all the poison damage you could
take all at once which can nuke your
whole team if you're not careful his
poison debuffs can't be blocked or
resisted either so you'll need shield
buffs and healing to counteract the
damage or just the ability to remove the
debuffs directly and often if you can
cleanse debuffs on this boss you'll be
good to go he doesn't have many other
tools at his disposal and the game is
updated regularly so this month there's
special events every day a bunch of
awesome new champions and a brand new
huge feature guardian ring that gives
you a load of new ways to use your
champions and at the start of december
raid's releasing one of its biggest most
anticipated features ever take a look at
this it looks insane with all these new
updates and an even bigger one right
around the corner
now's the perfect time to get started
and raid if you wait any longer you're
going to get left behind if you want to
get a huge head start in raid all you
have to do is hit the link in the
description or scan my qr code and
you'll get epic hero chanarow who's
amazing in the doom tower
200k silver one xp boost one energy
refill and one ancient shard so you can
summon an awesome champion as soon as
you get in game see you there now back
to the video if you haven't seen the
show or maybe you have take this journey
with me back to the very beginning
no no no no no no not that let's start
even earlier but we'll get to that
whenever people talked about 90s x-men
growing up i always imagined this
the 1989 pilot that was never picked up
for a series now dubbed pride of the
x-men
because this was the only older x-men
cartoon i watched as a kid i was born in
98 so the animated series wasn't on
anymore just reruns on channels i didn't
watch and by the time i was old enough
to care about these shows evolution was
in full swing so i didn't feel the need
to seek out the older one but i had a
vhs tape of this before i get into the
90s show i feel it's interesting to have
some contacts with this 30 minute pilot
that came a few years before narrated by
stanley the manly lee welcome this is
stanley of marvel comics warning you to
look around you your classmates your
friends you never know which one of them
may be a mutant it's lighthearted and
fast-paced and doesn't dwell on anything
too heavy
it's the story of kitty pryde being
inducted into the x-men spitefully named
school for freaks and weirdos and
helping stop magneto's brotherhood of
unsubtlety from unleashing a doomsday
weapon to blow up the earth
it has a real 80s action cartoon feel
here's the good guys here's the bad guys
they fight gi jones cobra autobots and
decepticons he-man and skeletor normal
people versus twitter users it's really
well animated but it's just too simple
it doesn't have the biting commentary
that makes x-men important and relevant
the themes are too surface level it
doesn't want to bog anyone down by
reminding them of racism so it's just
super people punching each other i do
enjoy the look of the characters in this
version and they had a pretty decent
roster for the x-men somehow as a kid i
never noticed that wolverine had this
accent get with it the x-men don't have
room for whiny breath apparently the
creators were forced to make that change
because mad max and crocodile dundee
were popular at the time oh you don't
want a piece of fruit
kids welcome her white she's not torn in
the x-men is he she's just a kid
wolverine what's the matter with this
bozo
an australian playing me that'll be that
a actually
what
they end the episode by making us think
nightcrawler heroically sacrificed
himself and kitty laments that the
eccentric comic relief teammate has
given his life for a noble cause except
this show doesn't have the stones for
that so he's fine
if anyone wants to get into the 90s
x-men show they should see this first so
they can get a feel for all the things
that this show is not
and what kind of show it was expected to
be at the time even if you're not a
comic book historian it's still a fun
watch and can put the following series
into more perspective
both are good takes on the characters
but one has so much more going on under
the hood worth looking at 90s x-men is
more about something
pride of the x-men is what you'd
probably expect the 90s series to be and
that wouldn't be bad but wouldn't be
that special or unique either it'd just
be more of a lot of the 80s style good
guys versus bad guy cartoons we've all
seen before and those are awesome
but x-men the animated series is
something else three years after pride
of the x-men failed to take off but it
did launch a really good arcade game
where colossus does that scream
hilarious
[Music]
then we got x-men the animated series
starring canadian wolverine oh thank god
i'm so happy that we live in the
universe where this became the default
accent that was a close one would've
probably been easier on you though
instead of kitty pride our point of
entry into this world is jubilee she's a
young mutant girl who feels
misunderstood and is taken in by xavier
and his team so she can finally feel at
home it's a contractual obligation that
every x-men adaptation starts with a shy
teenage mutant girl being taken in by
the school and taught about her powers
it's a bit cliche but it works pretty
well every time because it's a
convenient way to introduce the concept
of the x-men without doing an entire
origin story for them but in this one we
spend more time with jubilee seeing her
feel isolated from her foster parents
being a fish out of water in public and
almost being abducted by a giant robot
allegory we get a better sense of why
life as a mutant is harder than it is
for a normal person she's alone and
subject to a lot of prejudice even going
to the mall can be dangerous when the
whole world wants them dead for being
themselves in pride of the x-men
shadowcat just gets the mansion and says
no one in her life knows she's a mutant
here we get to see why that's a secret
worth keeping instead of just being told
flash forward in the episode after
jubilee has been officially recruited
and the x-men are running a more
grounded mission destroying the factory
that builds sentinels giant robot mutant
hunters that make for great video game
bosses as their ground team assaults the
compound they're overwhelmed by enemy
forces and beast is captured alive while
morph the shape-shifting comic relief
is killed i mean it's a kid's cartoon he
can't be dead right it's gotta be a fake
out he's gonna be fine by the end of the
episode cause status quo for all we know
morphin beast may still be alive beast
is
[Music]
oh geez yeah he's dead i guess until
he's resurrected as like an evil zombie
by mr sinister later on because this is
a comic book show but still the fact
that they left the episode hanging on
his demise and have characters still
reeling over it episodes later is nuts
in a lot of shows from a little bit
before this like gi joe or he-man this
wouldn't be possible because
mortality and grieving the loss of a
friend is a mature concept for a kid's
show transformers got away with it by
just putting all of that in the pg-13
movie released in theaters
so this was a new thing for network
shows of this caliber even spider-man
couldn't mention death everyone just
goes to different dimensions what
happened to morph is a great example of
one of my favorite things about this
show there are actual consequences in
each episode matters
beast is arrested and remains in jail
for the entire season we see multiple
stages of his court trial for the attack
on the factory we see how his case is
viewed by the politicians and the public
as well as other mutants he becomes the
poster boy for the entire mutant rights
movement and as the season progresses we
check back in on his storyline multiple
times
he has the opportunity to break out of
his confinement after magneto tries to
spring him and the other x-men meet him
on an unrelated jailbreak for colossus
midway through the season and both times
he passes it up because he thinks it
would help their cause if he sticks with
it and serves his time episodes bleed
into each other in other ways too
like this episode where scott and gene
are fighting a group of deformed mutants
in the sewers who want cyclops because
he's so manly
to serve my people i need a companion
someone to provide me
and wolverine's secretly in love with
gene
yeah that's that
it's that thing you remember that day
everyone knows that thing so seeing that
her and cyclops aren't breaking up
anytime soon causes him to leave this
was back in the day before the love
triangle was solved with adjoining
bedrooms and slightly more open minds
so much insufferable pining could have
been skipped in those movies and that
sets up the plot for the next episode
now wolverine's out on his own in canada
being hunted by sabertooth
in the b plot the x-men investigate an
island resort that claims to be mutant
friendly they go there and get forced
into slavery by the same d-bags from the
sentinel factory using collars that
disable their powers and that plot ends
on a cliffhanger while wolverine finally
comes to his senses and decides to go
home and that leads into the next
episode where he joins in the effort to
free them
most episodes do something to set up the
next one immediately after and every
season has its own long story arc in the
background of each story that leads to
the season finale
season one being beast's battle against
the corrupt justice system season two
having charles and magneto stranded on a
strange island without their powers
and you know seeing how the team has to
manage without them
and season three is all about the
phoenix saga and so on it may seem sort
of paltry and common now but having
continuity like this between episodes
for an animated show was pretty unheard
of
shows like spectacular spider-man
followed this model to tell some great
stories but the 90s x guys did first
most of the time animated shows from
this era would be a villain of the week
show with a single 22-minute one-off
story that's easily digestible with no
prior knowledge of the events going on
and everything in the status quo would
be reset by the end of the episode every
single time
you can watch any episode of he-man or
transformers and pretty much know
exactly what's going on and it always
wraps up in a nice bow at the end
without really dragging out into
anything longer except for like
multi-part episodes but even those are
just self-contained but x-men broke the
mold by being serialized instead of
episodic and of course being about more
than your typical heroes versus villain
stories among these action figure
cartoons of the time and even the movie
series couldn't get as deep into the
nitty-gritty of this stuff because they
were hampered by the two-hour running
time and two to four year gaps between
sequels the show could sit down and
lower the stakes and develop everything
more in depth and with more nuance i've
always thought that long-running
animated shows are much better for
adapting comic stories than film because
they have that room to breathe and no
limitations of budget for their concepts
much like invincible these days x-men
can tell some long and faithful
adaptations of the source material
without having to oversimplify or
condense it all to fit sometimes the
story needed to be told over the course
of nine episodes and that's fine often
the show faces the x-men with problems
they can't just punch to death like
political movements against them
media campaigns spreading false
information about mutants hate groups
gaining public favor scientists trying
to cure mutants instead of helping them
become more accepted and so the show
asks moral questions where the answer
isn't always immediately clear
was cyclops wrong for leaving morph and
beast behind even if it saved the rest
of the team and allowed them to fight
another day if a mutant like rogue who
physically harms people by just touching
them
had the ability to be cured should she
take it sometimes the questions get even
bigger and more philosophical with
dumbass time travelers cable and bishop
bishop comes from the days of future
past apocalypse and is going back to
influence events from the 90s to stop
mutant genocide but cable is from an
even further point in the future where
it's the apocalypse apocalypse and some
of the stuff bishop does to stop his
apocalypse makes the distant future even
worse
so we have this cool conflict of them
both going back to the same moment in
time to argue about the needs of the
many versus the needs of the few the
time travel stuff is well utilized
because they generally keep it simple we
get to see one version of the events
influenced by bishop where apocalypse
kills them all then we get to see the
same 20-minute episode again with cable
getting involved and changing the ending
slowly but surely throughout the story
coming up with a way that he can protect
both versions of the future all these
moral quandaries make the conflicts
between characters really interesting
and layered everyone's got a different
idea of how to solve the problem and
this stuff's a little more heady than
the usual we gotta stop the villains
doomsday weapon sort of cartoon plots
that superheroes often face x-men
doesn't hold the audience's hand it knew
that kids would be able to understand
and ponder these topics it doesn't hold
back on its themes like the more
watered-down 89 cartoon did
some of this stuff still feels relevant
today mostly because you know nothing
ever changes
hey
you're one of those plane carrying
mutants
plane carriers
you won't infect anybody else they were
very clever about finding scenarios to
slot mutants in as an allegory for
multiple different minority groups that
were struggling in america
from different races being treated
unfairly to foreign immigrants like
colossus trying to find work to the
working class struggling for livable
wages to this anti-mutant hate leader
reacting to his dad being saber-tooth
like it was a bigot discovering his
father was gay it's not as blunt of a
metaphor as some of the movies in terms
of handling lgbt themes
have you tried
not being a mutant
in fact they may not have even intended
that as a reading maybe it was just
meant to be the racism allegory by
itself but i still think it's a valid
reading nonetheless yeah this shows
preachy sjw trash and it was awesome for
a big whoop wanna fight about it but
it's still very much the x-men filtered
through the political lens of the 90s
and as such we also get a lot of comic
book [ __ ] from the 90s too
cable was a super new character at the
time so it was cool to see him get so
much love in this show same goes for a
lot of other marvel characters that bump
into the story from time to time like
miss marvel captain america alpha flight
punisher a few times and lucky there's a
deadpool he doesn't appear directly it's
usually just in memories or
shapeshifters trying to get wolverine
riled up with someone from his past
but it's damn cool to see him in there
at all and know a version of him exists
alongside this spider-man
all right webb head
i heard about what you said to iceman
no one embarrasses the x-men with their
poor social skills but me
that's right eventually we get a
crossover episode with spider-man the
animated series too
and uh cameo in dark phoenix looking at
their appearance in spider-man i noticed
how distinct this show's animation style
is
even from adjacent marvel cartoons on
the same network at the same time they
have three tone shading and heavy inking
to really sell that comic book in motion
look
shading the characters this way makes
every single frame of animation just
that much more complicated to draw and
takes so much more time the show looking
as slick as it does is a testament to
the animator's skill keeping everyone
consistent on model with all these
colors to put on
compare this to a show with a smaller
animation budget like spider-man which
settled at only two-tone shading i
appreciate the level of effort it took
to get this show's visual style looking
how it did without going overboard like
that avengers cartoon that was a busy
mess of colorful airbrushed vomit
let me get this straight poindexter
your eyes are portals to a dimension
full of lasers realize how stupid that
sounds you think my hands are portals to
the stabbing dimension how about i open
a portal to the pain dimension
i can't stay mad at you sweetheart come
here and a further contrast from
spider-man it wasn't as afraid of
potential censorship and the fight
scenes have some punching and violence
nothing too crazy but not toothless
either plus who doesn't love the intro
for this show
which one i don't know all three of them
are great look at the ones from japan
too
man anything feels more badass just
listening to that song just play over
doing the dishes folding laundry doing
taxes don't take my analysis of this
show the wrong way it's a little more
heady and serious than shows of its kind
but it's also silly weird and dumb fun
too
cody please come with us i bet the
professor can find some way to help you
we see islands full of dinosaurs giant
robots alien reality show hosts
kidnapping the x-men for an episode of
the hottest show on intergalactic cable
cameos from punisher an episode about
rogue stealing miss marvel's brain on
accident for like five years time
travelers busting in and messing up
events left and right and a christmas
special i reviewed a few years back but
as silly as all of this sounds it's
still in service of great stories and
character arcs and never feels like it's
dipping too far into ridiculousness for
me i love the way this show balances
everything so it's not too dull and sad
but also not too silly and off the wall
but this show does really commit to
story arcs for two three or even four
part episodes
so if you're not into that story off the
bat you might be bored for a little
while
it's a lot like real comic books in that
way god i wish they'd just stop doing
this event tie-in and get back to the
actual thing i care about another thing
i respect this show for is its restraint
a big turn off for me getting into x-men
movies and comics is that there's like 3
000 characters in the roster changes at
the drop of a hat like superhero musical
chairs so you can never get too attached
to like anything
but this show establishes its main
roster in the first episode and then
never changes it sure all of the other
x-men characters exist and appear like
colossus nightcrawler bishop iceman
but they're all minor appearances that
hop in once in a while instead of
permanently joining the team iceman was
a member of the first class team and we
get an episode about him with some
flashbacks to the kirby lee era of the
team in their old costumes but now he's
a solo act that the x-men team up with
for one and done he's uh
he's been busy hanging out with
spider-man i guess
for a show like this adding more and
more characters with each passing
episode would have been a great way to
pump out more and more action figures to
sell but they showed restraint keeping
the main cast tight and focusing mostly
on them
for one it helps us get more attached to
this set of characters and learn more
about them without getting overshadowed
too quickly by new additions i suppose
the action figure sales were driven by
the comics at the time because x-men was
huge in the 90s
so the show didn't feel as pressured to
add more pallet swapped autobots and
lame gimmicks man the aerial bots and
stunted cons they suck
yeah that's right i said it let's fight
about it something i don't see people
mention about this series often is that
the art style changed in the final
season i suppose the budget was lowered
as the show was getting a little long in
the tooth and losing steam so the
characters were redesigned and taken
down to only two-tone shading something
about the redesigns makes this final
season feel a little off it's the same
characters but it's like not quite how i
remember them the final season is one of
if not the shortest and feels like a
fond farewell to the series you could
tell they were winding down because it
doesn't have the long overarching plot
it's almost like an anthology of
one-offs to say goodbye to the
characters and see them doing stuff we
haven't before like a flashback to
wolverine's time and the big one helping
captain america punch nazis look at this
show's obvious political agenda yikes
bizarrely enough the show ends on an
episode where professor x is basically
assassinated by an anti-mutant extremist
on live television he's in critical
condition in the care of the team and
the attack on him creates mutant riots
and uprisings all over the world
led by magneto
much like pretty much every time they
fought him so far magneto is too tough
for them
but he backs down when he realizes his
old friend is dying we then have a
heartfelt goodbye from charles barely
clinging to life telling his team how
proud they made him
then he dies
but fear not crying traumatized child in
1997
lylandra of the shia empire and
professor x's cool space girlfriend that
he's in a long-distance relationship
with arrives to say that she can extend
his life on her homeworld
but only while he's with the empire
meaning that they can keep him alive
at the cost of never seeing him again
with a heavy heart they say goodbye to
charles xavier for the final time and he
lets the x-men know he will always be
with them in spirit
that's a bummer to end on jesus man
i think i respect that they only
slightly pulled their punch on that one
by compromising that he's still
technically alive
but he might as well have just died in
this scene and i i don't think it
lessened the impact any
x-men tas never played around and had a
lot of faith in its audience i was never
afraid to grab a big meaty handful of
uncomfortable subject matter and throw a
wad of it straight at a denim jacket
wearing child's face because the 90s and
the show knew they could take it so it
rarely held back and that level of
maturity and clarity of vision really
set it apart from a lot of shows before
it before batman was in melancholy noir
series skirting dark territory before
spider-man told the serialized
day-to-day life and times of peter
parker before gargoyles before spawn
there was x-men breaking the mold by
trying something a little different and
risky it's a product of its time
but it's also revolutionary in spite of
that it was a massive success both in
ratings and critically when it came out
because
it was something so fresh and bold but i
think a lot of younger audiences aren't
aware of that and think it might just be
something like pride of x-men
so to hear people these days say they
haven't watched it or their impression
of it is that it's cheesy and dumbed
down compared to later incarnations the
x-men
is a sad sight because they'd probably
love it if they gave it a chance
like i said i didn't grow up with this
show and i have no nostalgia for it at
all i didn't watch it until i was 19.
but i find myself blown away by its
strengths now that i've checked it out
as an adult
it's absolutely worth your time because
the series encapsulates everything x-men
is about and knows how to balance the
fun spandex wearing punchy adventures
with ideas that apply to the real world
around you even today
this show is instrumental to bringing
the x-men into over 23 million
households and paving the way for the
2000 feature film that sparked the
beginning of the superhero renaissance
and film
if you haven't seen it before give it a
chance and if you have
well
watch it again i guess
addendum just as i was finishing this
video season six got confirmed and
they're just doing more episodes of this
with all the original cast that are
still alive
i messaged cal dodd right after i saw
the announcement he's going to be the
main wolverine voice again after 25
years so it looks like this video is
kind of a warm up for him that's awesome
i hope in the new episodes they give
deadpool lines this time
all right xavier where are you i heard
someone was keeping you in this dump
said mr sinister
i think you have the wrong address fella
the door wasn't even locked
well you look a lot shorter in person
who are you
xavier but a different one instead i sit
in a chair all day watching 90s cartoons
hey would you mind reading this for me
subscribe to xavier for more videos like
this one also special thanks to the
incredibly talented cal dodd for
providing a voice for the old canuckle
head in this video
and a big thank you to jacob and ben for
editing this and dane for his art hey
what is this
some kind of dorky internet thing
yeah pretty much oh also do you want to
hang out hmm
all right
you into neon genesis evangelion
i'm really into that show right now
man you are from the 90s in fact i like
a lot of japanese stuff
[Music]
[Music]
you